The Recommendations Row is a central
feature of the Android TV home screen.
You can place recommendations here
to prominently feature content, and
to enable your users to
effortlessly start playback.
Notice that when the recommendation
part is selected the background image of
the home screen changes to reflect it.
In code,
recs work a lot like notifications.
Basically, you issue a recommendation
by creating a notification.
Cool, right?
As apps issue notifications, they're
collected by the Notification Manager.
The Leanback Launcher then displays
these notifications as recommendation
cards in the recommendations row
on the Android TV home screen.
To create a good user experience,
Android TV
looks at all the available recs and
ranks them using an internal algorithm.
The more often a user picks
one of your recommendations,
the more prominently they'll
be displayed in the future.
Also, it's best practice not
to have more than two or
three recommendations
active at a single time.
Let's take a look at
how this works in code.
To make issuing recommendations easier,
the Leanback sample provides
the recommendation builder class.
This class uses the builder design
pattern to construct recommendations and
if you're curious check
out the instructor notes.
You can reuse this in your own code.
Let's take a look at how it works for
completeness.
First we'll issue notifications
using notification compat
which you saw on the wearables section.
This class is included with
the Android V4 support library.
let's take a look inside the build
method to see how we construct our
recommendation notification.
Scrolling down a bit you'll see here's
where we start construction our
notification.
You might be aware that notifications
have four available styles BigPicture,
BigText, Inbox, and Media.
Here we always use BigPicture, so we can
set a background image for the card.
Details on each style are in
the notes in you're curious.
Scrolling down a bit more to indicate
this notification is actually
a recommendation.
We set a category like this.
We need to set both a Large and
Small icon.
The SmallIcon is drawable resource for
a badge icon on the card, and
the LargeIcon is used as
the card background image.
We setLocalOnly to true to
indicate this notification is for
the current device only.
To learn more about the other fields,
check out the link in
the instructor notes.
Also notice that when
a recommendation card is selected,
the background image of the Android TV
home screen changes to reflect it.
The image we used for
the background image is a large bitmap.
It's too big for a notification.
Instead, we'll use a content
URI to provide its location.
But first, to serve this image,
we'll use a sample content provider and
implement only its open file method.
We'll do this right inside
the recommendation builder class and
here's how our bare bones
content provider looks.
The only method with
implementation is Open File.
A ParcelFileDescriptor by the way,
is used to send a file descriptor
across different file processes.
In this case, from our sample app
to the Leanback Launcher app.
Moving back to the build method,
here's how we get a background image.
Notice by the way that this method is
also called insider content provider
to resolve the background
image from an ID.
At this point, we can create a content
URI that indicates the background image.
We put this notification
into the bundle using
the Extra_Background_Image_URI key.
Finally, we'll set a pending
intent to take users straight to
the details fragment when they
select our recommendation.
If you prefer, you can also
jump directly into playback.
To see how this works we'll need to
take a look at another class called
UpdateRecommendationService.
We'll use this class to keep our
recommendations current by updating
them from time to time.
And performing small job regularly
sounds like a perfect job for
an intent service.
We'll actually start this service
when an Android TV boots up and
we'll see how to do that shortly.
First, let's cover what it does.